اقررت السعوديه ضوابط جديده خاصه بمعالجه
طلبات ايقاف الخدمات من ابرزها انشاء
المنصه الالكترونيه الموحده وايضا تنفيذ
الجهات الحكوميه للقرار خلال مده لا
تتجاوز 180 يوما
اقرت السعوديه ضوابط محدثه لنظام ايقاف
الخدمات وهو اجراء يترتب عليهم امتناع
جهات حكوميه عن تقديم الخدمات لفرد او
مؤسسه
وشملت الضوابط انشاء المنصه الالكترونيه
الموحده لايقاف الخدمات تشرف عليه 13 جهه
ومنظمه حكوميه واهليه من ضمنها هيئه حقوق
الانسان المنصه الموحده تمكن الفرد او
الجهه من طلب تمديد المده قبل ايقاف
الخدمات كما تتيح خيار وقف قرار الايقاف
والغائه خلال 24 ساعه فقط ايقاف الخدمات
المحدث لا يشمل العلاج والتعليم والعمل
والسجل التجاري وتوقيع الوقائع المدنيه
والاوراق الثبوتيه
واكدت الضوابط المحدثه على عدم تاثر
التابعين للشخص الموقوفه خدماته باي اضرار
180 يوما هي المده المحدده لجمع الجهات
لتطبيق ضوابط المحدثه لنظام ايقاف الخدمات
التي تراعي مصالح الموقوفين وتضمن مرونه
عاليه في الاجراءات
انضم الينا في استديوهاتنا من رياض
المحامي الدكتور محمد العيسى حياك الله
دكتور
يعني اولا ما ميزه هذه الضوابط الجديده
ولماذا تتخذ في البدايه هي ضوابط يعني
خلينا ناخذ تصور عن فكره
الضوابط الدائمه والانظمه واهدافها دائما
في جميع الدول هي عمليه عاده تنظيميه يكون
الهدف منها يعني تحديد الممارسات بحيث انه
ما يكون في يعني نوع من التباين في الجهات
الاخرى او الجهات المسؤوله عن تطبيق هذه
الضوابط سواء كانت حكوميه او غيرها
بحيث انه ما يكون في نوع من التعارض او
التباين او الاضطراب الهدف من هاي الضوابط
هي تحديد وتنظيم الممارسه السابقه في
موضوع فيما يتعلق في في ايقاف الخدمات
نلاحظ مثلا كانت في فترات من الفترات فت
فتره من الفترات كان يتضرر من ايقاف
الخدمات التابعين مثلا يتضرر الشخص نفسه
ليش الضرر هذا يعني مثلا اثبات واقعه
ولاده او مثلا
او مثلا في الصحه او مدارس او المدارس او
التعليم او العمل
نصت عليها الضوابط ان هذه الامور كلها لا
تخضع لايقاف الخدمات باعتبار انها اما
تكون متعديه على التابعين او انها الضرر
للشخص نفسه ضرر بالغ يعني ضرر غير غير
عادي
فلذلك جت الضوابط لضبط هذه الامور
شو الفرق بين المراحل الثلاث منخفضه الاثر
متوسطه الاثر وعاليه الاثر وعلى من يتم
تطبيقها طيب الضوابط جت الفكره مختلفه عن
التطبيق السابق جت قالت بدل من ندخل
مباشره على موضوع ايقاف الخدمات باقصى حد
نعطي تدريب للموضوع اول شيء اللجنه قبل
المراحل في لجنه
تشكل موجب هذه الضوابط لقبول واعتماد
الطلبات التي تتقدم من جهه حكوميه لايقاف
الخدمات الامر الثاني اللجنه قبل ان تبث
في الطلب تبلغ الشخص المعني باسباب ايقاف
الخدمات فقد يعالج الامر
يتم تحيد فكره ايقاف الخدمات الامر الثالث
تبدا ايقاف الخدمات بمراحل مرحله
المنخفضه الاثر ثم المرحله التاليه اللي
متوسطه الاثر ثم عاليه الاثر الفرق بينها
فيما يتعلق بمتوسط منخفضه الاثر يكون
ايقاف الخدمات يستفيد منها الشخص سواء كان
على المستوى الفرد او على مستوى قطاع
الاعمال فمثلا بدلا ان تتقدم المنشفه في
قطاع الاعمال بطلب خدمه جديده هذه تكون
المرحله الاولى لكن لو كان نشاطها قائم
تريد ان تتوسع فيه مرحله التطبيقيه مرحله
المرحله الاولى فقط فهذا لا يخضع للقاف
طيب ما استجاب وما تعدلت الاشكاليه او
الطلب المطلوب منه او الى اخره في المرحله
الاولى تنتقل
تنفيذ ايقاف الخدمات للمرحله التاليه
المرحله التاليه هي متوسطه الاثر يصير اي
شيء يتعلق بتوسيع النشاط ايضا يخضع لي
ايقاف انتهت المده ولم يتم معالجه
الاشكاليه من قبل هذا ترتفع لايقاف
الخدمات القابله للايقاف مع التاكيد على
استثناء عمليه
ما يتعلق بالاضرار به او بالتابعين فيما
يتعلق التعليم تطبيق بيختلف اليوم يعني
بعد النظام الجديد
بيكون التطبيق عباره عن منصه خاصه
الكترونيه لهذه الضوابط تخضع لاداره
وصلاحيات اللجنه اللجنه مكونه من اكثر من
ما يقارب 13 جهه حكوميه برئاسه وزاره
الداخليه
ومشاركه عدد من الجهات الحكوميه والوزارات
تتقدم الجهه الحكوميه بتقدير بطلب ايقاف
الخدمه وايقاف الخدمات بموجب نموذج معتمد
من اللجنه نفسها يوضح فيه سبب
الطلب هذه الطلبه الخدمات وايضا مستند
نظامي الضوابط اكدت على ان لا يتم ايقاف
الخدمات الا بموجب سند نظامي او قرار
قضائي او مرسوم ملكي او ما شابه ذلك فلا
يكون لايقاف الخدمات ارتجالا وايضا اكدت
الضوابط على ان لا يكون ايقاف الخدمات
لغرض الطلب من المواطن او الفرد المراجعه
لا توقف الخدمه لاجل هذا فقط وانما هو
لاغراض اخرى ستطبق
يعني في القضايا الجديده
ام انه سيتم تطبيقها حتى على المتضررين
سابقا
تراجع ربما النص لا هو بيكون باثر رجعي
لكن في مرحله انتقاليه وايضا النص النص
الضابط في اخرها انه يكون
يكون التطبيق هذه الضوابط بعد 180 يوم من
نشرها نشرت اليوم فبعد 180 يوم تدخل في
حيز التنفيذ مثل اي ضوابط او قواعد يعني
معناته سيتم مراجعه كل القضايا السابقه لا
يقصد وانتهى انما فيما يتعلق في من اوقف
خدماته الان فيكون يخضع الضابط الجديد
الجديده